das okay hey leute was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video ja ich hoffe natürlich euch geht
es gut jetzt ihr seht schon jetzt schon
lachen und zwar was passiert wohl wenn
man bei demselben lieferservice in dem
zeitraum von sage ich mal zwei stunden
vielleicht auch drei stunden einfach so
acht mal bestellt und was passiert vor
allem wenn man eine bestellung aufgibt
über irgendeine seite wie lieferando
oder sonst war fünf minuten wartet und
dann bei derselben pizzeria das gleiche
noch mal bestellt also halt auch zum
liefern kommt dann weiter bestellungen
zusammen kommen die einzeln oder denken
sie sich vielleicht auch das ist jetzt
ein systemfehler dieser ganzen sache
wollen wir heute auf den grund gehen ich
habe nämlich einen coolen kommentar von
jemand von euch gelesen der mir das doch
mal vorgeschlagen haben das ist auch
wirklich so eine sache
da interessiert es mich selber extrem
was denn passiert also was wird heute
passiert ich kann als irgendwelche
vermutungen darüber aufstellen
vielleicht freuen die sich vielleicht
regen die sich auf vielleicht kommen die
nach dem zweiten oder dritten mal gar
nicht mehr
keine ahnung wir werden sehen ich will
gar nicht lange gelagert und ich würde
sagen wir starten einfach mal wenn ihr
sagt alex es ist mal wieder so eine
geniale idee dann lasst mir sehr gerne
daumen nach oben da und schreibt weitere
ideen die halt in die richtung jährige
kommentare wir haben jetzt gerade 12 uhr
41 also genau mittag ich würde sagen wir
bestellen mal entspannt eine pizza okay
es ist natürlich die frage macht das
wäre meiner stamm pizzeria wo ich weiß
okay das schmeckt ist wirklich gut
oder will ich mir irgendeine andere aus
damit ich nicht obwohl bei ich mach das
jetzt über lieferando da kommt dann
wahrscheinlich eben externer liefert
übte deswegen würde ich sagen er macht
es bei meiner stamm pizzeria da habe ich
auch zwei sachen mit denen ich genau auf
den mindestbestellwert komme und die
bestellen wir dann einfach die ganze
zeit wir starten hier mit mama geriet
mit paprika boom und dazu kommen einfach
dieses spaghetti napoli
hier sind dabei zehn euro das kann man
auch super wurden im kühlschrank
aufbewahren
also es wird keine verschwendung oder so
das kann ich euch hier schon noch
versprechen ja jetzt bestellen ok
perfekt lieferzeit beträgt ungefähr 35
minuten dh wir warten jetzt so lange
und wenn die pizza dann angekommen ist
bestelle ich halt direkt nochmal und
dann noch mal und dann noch mal dann
vielleicht noch mal und dann noch mal
und vielleicht dann auch noch mal keine
ahnung also leute erstes bestellt ich
warte jetzt auf dem balkon bisher kommt
machen die tür auf dann verstehe ich
noch schnell die kamera das war's dann
auch eigentlich schon ich bin wirklich
mal gespannt ich hoffe es kommt dann
auch immer der gleiche weil sonst
irgendwie dumm wir werden sehen also
dass vielleicht kommt mir gern bei
instagram 30 alex wie die parken sogar
meistens genau da auf unserem
bürgersteig manchmal sogar mit seinem
roller scheiße leute bist und du hast
[Applaus]
[Musik]
leute also dass du willst du das
angekommen das war der pizzalieferant
oder ich auch gar nicht so wichtig mal
gucken wie oft er heute noch hinkommen
wird ich hoffe halt auch dass der gleich
wieder kommen ist aber müsste eigentlich
sein weil ich wüsste jetzt nicht warum
nicht sagen was versucht haben wir die
nudeln die sind echt richtig lecker und
hier noch die pizza zieht auch echt nice
aus bevor wir das jetzt allerdings essen
müssen wir noch mal bestellen leute ich
bin wirklich so ich denke mir was machst
du hier schon wieder
also ich muss jetzt nicht wieder meinen
bildschirm aufnehmen ich bestelle das
einfach genau das gleiche nochmal
baguette sagt 10 euro bestellen
ich schreibe jetzt mal dazu pizza
schneiden wäre super sagt sie bezahlen
okay ich bin ja mal gespannt ob jetzt
genau die gleiche lieferzeit ist weil
die 35 minuten die eben angegeben waren
haben eigentlich gut gepasst vielen dank
wir haben dann auch schon wieder 35
minuten also deutschland jetzt heißt es
wieder warten ich habe mir auch schon
die bestätigungs mail bekommen und wir
sind uns dann gleich wieder ein paar
sekunden später selber bestimmt ach so
ja das muss noch mal sorry da geht das
okay nein nein das war schon richtig es
ist doch schon bezahlt oder ok super-gau
genau das war was ich gedacht hat weiß
ich glaube wenn ich glaube wenn ich eine
pizzeria würde ich das gleiche denken
wenn jemand hat dann einfach noch mal
das gleiche bestellt so das kann doch
nicht sein die frage ist nur was
passiert wenn man es dann noch mal
bestellen an sich ist ja auch nur umsatz
für dieses ding ist ja nicht schlecht
aber gut
leute ich renne es doch schnell zum
supermarkt weil ich muss nochmal geld
wechseln ist ja immer nett wenn man auch
trinkgeld gibt vor allem beim
pizzaservice wenn ich mal gut wenn man
dann auch in euro oder 2 euro trinkgeld
gibt deswegen muss ich mich jetzt bei 1
wir haben 35 minuten zeit länger nicht
die kommen wir mal pünktlich bis gleich
okay leute jetzt war ich mal im
supermarkt habe es schneller zeit
hiervon aus zu essen man muss wirklich
sagen das ist die geilste pizza also
ich habe noch nie so eine leckere pizza
das ist richtig schön dünn und dann auch
noch geliefert also also wirklich eine
richtig schüler nahmen das problem ist
halt nur einstellig comdirect die
nächste
[Musik]
leute ich hab ja eigentlich gehofft es
kommt der gleiche
das liegt wahrscheinlich daran weil die
zeit über die verwandlung bestelle dass
die hat mehrere fahrer haben aber auch
bei einer pizzeria kann man es ja
sonders mehrere fahrer da sind aber es
gab kein problem
wir bestellen jetzt einfach noch mal und
jetzt habe ich noch mal richtig einen
raus leute jetzt bin ich wirklich mal
gespannt was jetzt passieren wäre es
bleibt mir nichts anderes übrig als
direkt weiter zu machen und ich bin mal
gespannt was jetzt passieren wird also
eben hat der typ ja schon angerufen und
gefragt ob ich das wirklich ernst meine
und ob ich das wirklich noch mal
bestellt hat und jetzt gehen wir halt
wirklich aufs ganze und wie das zeige
ich euch kurz so leute ich habe wieder
das gleiche bestellt waren warm und
kauft das jetzt so leute vielen dank für
deine moore jetzt beträgt 40 minuten der
tag wird auf jeden fall ganz schön teuer
an so 10 euro beim so als er gesehen ich
bin mal gespannt ob ich jetzt wieder
anrufe wir bestellen allerdings wir
warten das kurz 23 minuten und bestellen
dann das gleiche nochmal das heißt sie
haben noch mal zwei bestellungen die
komplett gleich sind wie die vorherigen
zwei auch und die kommen nahe von zwei
bis drei minuten an
also die denken sich wirklich so jetzt
kann man sich eigentlich noch denken
will dieser typ uns verarschen so
eigentlich schon
[Musik]
ok ich würde sagen drei minuten sind rum
sagt zahlungspflichtig bestellen aber
eben gar nicht ob wir die zweite kürzer
geschnitten haben bezahlen sagt ihr
könnt ihr sie nächste bestellung wieder
40 minuten ich kann euch sehr gerne
gleich auch mal den screenshot einbinden
von meinem paypal account damit ihr
sehen können dass das wirklich fünf mal
bestellt wurde
nicht dass einige sagen wo das aber
fällt was du damals 100 prozent will
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt eigentlich
müsste jetzt ein angekommen war jetzt
zumindest ebenso also falls ja melde ich
mich wenn wir uns leicht leute irgendwie
hab ich schnell sind die leute aber was
ich mich jetzt frage ich habe das ja
gesehen ich habe also die waren wieder
extrem schnell
nur ich habe ja das gleiche noch zwei
anstellt und hier habe ich jetzt nur
einmal bekommen ist dass hier irgendwas
drauf gemalt
ok also eigentlich müsste es jetzt in
drei minuten noch mal klingeln sollte
was geht kleines zwischenfazit also ich
hab ja eigentlich damit gerechnet dass
sie mich wieder anrufen als kam kein
angebot
und ich vermisse jetzt auch schon seit
über zehn 15 minuten die vierte
bestellung also die es noch gar nicht da
also ich warte jetzt noch ein bisschen
ab und weißt du nicht kommen sollte ich
dann einfach mal dort an weil das geld
dafür ist halt schon überwiesen leute
also ich muss leider sagen ich war jetzt
schon echt lange auf die vierte
bestellung also das was ich halt
vielleicht ist die dass man leider nur
die leute die ersten wollen hallo ich
glaube wir hatten eben schon mal
telefoniert ich hatte noch mal danach
was bestellt noch mal genau das gleiche
genau richtig hören und die die zweite
kommt die noch
zu sehen war soll nach fertigstellung ja
ja alles klar
dankeschön jetzt frage ich mich entweder
bei diesem unternehmen arbeiten gebe es
viele menschen weil der dachträger jetzt
schon zum zweiten mal dass das ein
fehler war ich habe keine ahnung also
wir stellen jetzt nicht noch ein fünftes
mal und wenn da nichts passiert was
irgendwie außergewöhnlich ist dann weiß
ich auch nicht wie die lieferanten
werden einem immer älter wieder nichts
gesagt
so langsam an
leute ich frage mich wirklich also ich
dachte dass es so ist dass jedes
restaurant einen lieferanten hat
vielleicht zwei aber doch nicht vier
oder zumindest dass es einen gibt der
für diese region verantwortlich ist weil
der einzige der das jetzt schon richtig
komisch findet ist der staat mit dem
habe ich ja auch schon zweimal
telefoniert ist auch ein sehr netter wir
verstehen uns mittlerweile ist echt
richtig gut ich würde sagen wir machen
ist jetzt noch ein letztes mal wirklich
und wenn jetzt da nichts passiert dann
weiß ich ja auch nicht okay man muss
sagen das ist schon was passiert die
dachten sich zweimal das war ein fehler
naja kommt ich bestelle eben diesmal
dauert sogar nur 30 minuten wie hier
steht
ich kann euch gern mal den screenshot
hier ein werden von meinem paypal profil
wo ihr sehen könnt das ist wirklich fünf
bestellung war insgesamt genau 50 euro
plus fünf euro trinkgeld eigentlich
sogar sechs euro der ebene 2 gekriegt
aber wieder ein teures video und jetzt
warten wir darauf das ist das letzte mal
stellt oder ich noch einen anruf kriege
könnte ja auch sein was ich glaube der
gesetzt ok also zum fünften mal es ist
schon wieder ein anderer älter
[Musik]
das war voll als halb voll aggressiv
oder okay leute jetzt weiß ich
wenigstens dass nicht gecheckt haben
also dass ich halt so oft dargestellt
habe weil ich dachte so zwischendurch
die merken das gar nicht mehr wirklich
oder die interessiert seid nicht na ja
das habe ich schon wieder ein neues
essen zwei minuten haben wir schon
gegessen da sind noch zwei deutschen
ehrlich zu sein ich könnte jetzt noch
mal bestellen aber ich sage jetzt okay
das reicht es waren 50 euro die
reaktionen waren schon ganz witzig fand
ich und man muss es ja nicht provozieren
auch wenn es bestimmt dass sich werden
würde vielleicht würden die auch gar
nicht mehr wiederkommen wenn ich jetzt
noch mal machen würde sollte ich hoffe
dass ich wieder hat euch gefallen macht
am besten nicht nach einmal bestellen
reicht ja und wir sehen uns übermorgen
wieder gibt es neue haut rein